and my dad [ __ ] 100 year old man it
just feels dangerous for both of them so
[Music]
hi i'm joe list and i'm here to answer
the internet
would you rather be known as the best
sex ever by a bunch of normal girls or
the worst sex ever by a bunch of smokes
smokes mean like hot women
i feel like i'm 50 years old no i'm too
insecure i want to i want first of all a
normal girl is hot for me i'm not
exactly you know kicking ass out there
folks i mean i'm married my wife's
beautiful whatever
uh but yeah i'm gonna go best sex ever
which is pretty close to the truth
can you use a gift card on a first date
boy i am currently holding two gift
cards in my pocket there's a chipotle
with the amount in there i think there's
another one too
first date is tough um
there it is gift card
cards oh yeah i got great fans
great fans i carry my money like a
nine-year-old um
i'm gonna say no to the gift card on the
first date unless i mean i have to say
i'm doing well financially i remember
what it's like to be a loser
and uh if that's the only thing you can
do i think do it you're still paying so
yeah yeah you can what am i talking
about yeah would you rather the world
lost women or all sports oh that's
tricky
because there's a woman in the room here
but someone else can hit record um
i love my wife i love my wife i love her
she's the best she's number one but
sports are the only that's what i think
about sports it's the only time in your
life you get to say wow that was
unbelievable i can't believe that
my wife i believe i believe believe all
women
sports are unbelievable
would you rather go to heaven or become
a ghost on earth after you die oh i'm
staying on earth i love the earth earth
is number one it's the best place i've
ever been and ghosts you can hunt i want
to haunt i want to watch the games
heaven sucks
it feels like in heaven everyone's their
oldest version of themselves everyone's
like oh my grandfather i'm like why
would your grandfather be 85 in heaven
shouldn't he wouldn't he be 21
that's ridiculous so i'm staying on
heaven i'm going to haunt my wife and
you know blow my dad
[Laughter]
would you rather be the best looking
dude in the world or be able to read
minds
i would be the best looking dude because
reading minds is not dissimilar to
reading youtube comments i read youtube
comments it's the equivalent of reading
a mind and every time i do i want to
kill myself
i feel like if i could read minds at
least one person in this room right now
would be like this guy sucks
so
i'm going with best looking dude and
i've never really been particularly
attractive so i'm going best looking
dude easy
if you were a general in the civil war
and you could get a t-rex or modern war
tank
to fight on your side what are you
taking i don't know t-rex is not
trustworthy i don't feel like but they
are the good guys in jurassic park
very loyal um
i guess i gotta go t-rex i like their
little arms and a tank i don't operate a
tank am i operating the tank
yeah i'll go t-rex it seems fun i wanted
to be like uh once upon a time in
hollywood i'm like and then he you know
goes crazy all right how many rats would
it take to overwhelm and kill you in a
fight
oh i would say
two
i don't think i'll water i wouldn't fare
well with rats i mean i feel like one
time i did have a mouse running up my
hallway and like i was in front of the
door and i just kicked it like andy moog
and it went flying and died
so
one i could handle i think probably two
rats would [ __ ] me up
i just feel like i wouldn't do well with
the wraps
i went with andy mug i should have said
reggie lemlin or someone more recently
would you rather have to watch sports or
porn upside down for the rest of your
life i guess i'd do porn porn works i'm
a bit i like sports way more than i like
porn
because i'm old um
i'm gonna take i'll take porn upside
down that seems fun should you lock a
dog out of the room when you're having
sex absolutely i'm not a big dog guy in
fact i hate dogs and one time the last
woman i made loved to before my wife uh
she had a dog and the dog was literally
like
the whole time i couldn't get it hard or
keep it hard or
that might have been her looks but
either way
keep the dog out of the room i don't
want to get bit while i'm having sex by
her or the dog you have a choice between
a sum of money and world peace how much
money would it take for you to give up
world peace i mean i can't even follow
the logic of this question wait what i'm
like i am magical right you i can either
give world peace and it's like you
you gave the world work world peace okay
or i can give you money
so what what number would you would you
oh boy i'd like 50 60 bucks
no i don't know i mean it wouldn't have
to be i'm going to take world peace i
want the peace i like the peace i got
enough money how much money does a man
really need i made 48 grand last year i
know what i'm doing up here so i'm gonna
go with uh i'm gonna go with i don't
know 50 million dollars would you rather
live with your parents for the rest of
your life it should be their life
or always um they're like 70. or
or always have to use toilet paper as
napkins toilet paper is napkins i've
done that it's not great because there's
always [ __ ] all over them
um
you see what i did there
i made it use toilet paper my parents
are pretty fun i don't know i live with
my parents because they go to bed at
like 8 p.m and uh my dad likes sports so
i'd go with them my mother throw me a
few bucks every once in a while i live
with my parents it's free and they can
hear me [ __ ] learn a couple things
i think that would be fun would you
rather have to tell your mom everything
sexual you've ever done
or have to show her your entire porn
history i have to say i'm not a big porn
guy uh nobody believes me i don't watch
a lot of porn
but the history i do watch porn when i
do it's for curiosity so the history is
a little embarrassing because i'm a
little bit what's that look like
i'd rather tell my mom everything
sexually when i got herpes i called my
mother and i said i have herpes so she
knows a good amount about me she knows i
[ __ ] somebody with herpes and i have
blisters on my dick so i love you mom
i might do this anyways would you rather
get your girlfriend pregnant when you're
16 or get your wife pregnant when you're
60. i got to go 60 because i've had a
good life i didn't get anyone pregnant
when i was 16 or even have sex with
anyone when i was 16. i don't know when
you're 60 you can raise your kid for a
few years and then you move on you kick
off yeah
really yeah exactly exactly so i'm going
to take the wife pregnant at 60. i think
she'll be hot plus that's like uh at
this point i'd love her to be fat and
round and be kind of hot you know mix it
up would you rather spend the rest of
your life in a country music video or a
rap video
i think i'd go country music because i
feel like
i haven't watched a lot of music videos
in the last 30 years but
i just feel like country music at least
it's outside it's sunny it feels like
it's daytime like i feel like they're
they're out there it's warm
i feel like rap there's a lot of smoke
involved it's indoors it's like it's
dark lighting
i like the outdoors i want to breathe i
want to feel the sun but um i don't uh
enjoy country music or rap music really
either would you rather
a watch your dad [ __ ] a hundred year old
man
or b watch your mother kill someone
can i have both is there any way i can
do both
at the same time
i think i would rather my mother kill
someone because i think my mother
probably wants to kill some people
and uh i just think it'll be fun because
i'd like i kind of i think should be
good at it you know and my dad [ __ ]
100 year old man it just feels dangerous
for both of them so
i'm going to go with watch my mom kill
someone and if i could pick the woman
that would be or man
whoopsie
cut that
all right big thanks for watching ati
featuring joe list go check him out one
of the funniest comedians in the game he
deserves to be a superstar anybody else
who you want to see any up and coming
comics anybody who you think deserves to
be a superstar comment below we'll go
get em make sure you subscribe to the
channel right now